hello and welcome to this video cartoon
1703 with us
yeah maybe hello it could be the
classical Dutch nobody is going for the
stone wall many many possible lines
against it this is not to be believed to
be very critical I think what I'm
playing him but I recently looked at the
line just just briefly and felt that
it's not too bad it's not often
recommended it makes it in this case a
bit more difficult to play B six and one
ideas Bishop f4 and yet to trade
okay Bishop f4 he might just play g5 him
93 maybe also g5 hmm maybe
if not I just get Bishop f4 and okay
you know that that is satisfying him I'm
happy about that
really okay
not sure what h6 is doing weekends a bit
but I mean if he wanted to play g5 I
don't know if you need h6 for that whoa
ah okay okay
he spotted that Queen takes ninety two
wins the exchange that's absolutely true
so I'm so I'm losing the d4 pawn yeah I
mean the blacks position is so weakened
I don't I don't think this is some point
it was not intended but he's got so many
weaknesses that is not going to be good
anyway
I don't see how it's developing pieces
and let's see what he does it's kind of
difficult to make a move evening without
immediately I'm making it worse I only
have to avoid to move the D three night
because H is under some pressure
I don't understand anything what what's
happening here
I mean next move if I go F 3 then B 5 or
probably H 3 is also also problem for
black I mean it's got no square it's
just no square to go Jim yeah this one
now I can take on g4 also move the
knight can move it here
I'm 95 and I take okay sometimes you
have games where you never expect to
move like I mean never yeah so sometimes
it's just a good idea to stop worrying
and just play a play with at play and
play a play your game and don't think
about what the other guy might do
because you never get a move maybe that
was relatively speaking I'm not so
terrible I mean I think this is still
lost but at least it's a bit murky so I
take it we go see on a trip wins this
one night is having much stronger metal
could be a case of a bishop and night
major
oh this is a good bishop
okay okay no he would have gone to a six
but three three pieces is too much yeah
he that was a weird way to play the
Stonewall in many ways so this happened
and now yeah I was thinking maybe g5
here even I don't know g5 is very
principled at least I would have gone
I'd fe5 okay it's nothing trying to do
this it's a complicated position
tough tough to analyze really this is
surprising because you usually want to
prevent Bishop f4 if you can and h6 also
was weird just weakens the position were
no benefit okay now we I didn't I didn't
see him that he takes c4 was possible
when I played this move but the
compensation is really really strong
like here this this position is just bad
for like how much yeah not so bad not so
bad according to the comp if you go back
with the Queen to d7 or Queen to the aid
I probably would have played this move
and just claimed to be enjoying
compensation in something something like
that is not easy for black even though
the comp thinks it's kind of okay I
guess I mean the engine is not unnerved
by all those pieces close close blacks
yeah Knight g4 is just weird
it stumbles into into the situation
where there is no one nowhere to go
f3 b5 is not so clear I saw that this is
better for white but I think h3 is
better in comparison b5 yeah and now you
can argue no you can argue what to do
because there are many things that
advantageous this is for sure also very
good no I'm material is equal and blacks
position is just very uncoordinated but
95 is just simpler I only expected 95
now after which I would have taken and
taken and yeah it must be a pretty clear
advantage but it's not winning instead
he took on f2 so I took him here and now
Quincy 3 yeah the engine just wants to
take on c6 which is possible and this is
probably not even that clear if he takes
on c3 yeah I should grab c6 inside seems
and now it's a bit odd that he didn't
first weaken my structure still
surprised that I'm not better here the
reason is why I think I should be better
is that I mean those pawns are all weak
I mean weak weak weak and this doesn't
move so I thought I would win most of
the pawns but the engine finds some some
sort of equality with King h7 which is
not very intuitive on night X that has
Bishop d7 okay
[Music]
this route very hot very hot the
suggestion by the comp to go into self
in it wants to do something like this
let's say where you very reach this
position it's very difficult to ever
move a piece very very weird position
that never moves very odd yeah in the in
the game we get I'm sorry Quincy 3 get a
better version of that and now that the
pieces I of the points are indeed
falling the auntie stumbled stumbled
into this I had 97 immediately I just
see that but okay it's you can only get
one point per game ok guys thanks for
watching